DOING STORIES ABOUT SEA OTTER
HEALTH LAST NIGHT.
MEDIA HACKS WERE SPINNING THE
COMEY REPORT.
LET'S BRING IN JOHN YU.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
I WANT TO BEGIN WITH THIS FROM
CNN'S LEGAL ANALYST.
>> WHAT I THINK WE SHOULD NOT
LOSE SIGHT OF IS NONE OF THIS IS
ANY INDICATION FOR DONALD TRUMP.
IT DOESN'T CHANGE ANYTHING ABOUT
WHAT COMEY WAS WRITING ABOUT IN
THOSE MEMOS WHICH WAS DONALD
TRUMP DEMANDING LOYALTY OF HIM
AND TRYING TO GET HIM TO SHUT
DOWN THE INVESTIGATION.
THOSE ARE STILL OBSTRUCTIVE ACT.
TODAY'S FINDING ON COMEY HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH CLEARING
TRUMP.
>> Laura: HOW DID HE TURN THE
IG-REPORT SLAMMING COMEY AND
TURN IT INTO TRUMP IS NOT
VINDICATED?
>> I AM SAD TO SAY AFTER I READ
THE IG-REPORT.
TRUMP DIDN'T OBSTRUCT JUSTICE.
HE FREED THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
OF A MAN WHO REJECTED OUR
CONSTITUTION AND DEMOCRACY.
HE DECIDE THE NORMAL BASIC RULES
OF THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT DID
NOT APPLY TO HIM IN HIS CRUSADE
TO TOP PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WE DON'T FREELY SHARE THE
RESULTS OF CONFIDENTIAL
INVESTIGATIONS WITH THE "NEW
YORK TIMES" OR THE PRESS TO
ATTACK PEOPLE WE DON'T LIKE.
WE KEEP THOSE THINGS
CONFIDENTIAL TO PURSUE
SUCCESSFUL INVESTIGATIONS.
IN JIM COMEY WAS A NORMAL
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT PROSECUTOR OR
A LYING FBI AGENT HE WOULD HAVE
BEEN FIRED ON THE SPOT.
>> Laura: NO QUESTION.
HERE'S MSNBC'S LEGAL ANALYST'S
TAKE.
>> PEOPLE TALKING TO FORMER
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT EMPLOYEES,
THEY SAY HOROWITS IS MISSING THE
PINT.
IT'S LIKE PUNISHING SOMEONE
SPEEDING TO PUT OUT A FIRE.
>> THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
HE SHOULD HAVE NEVER BEEN THE
FBI DIRECTOR.
HE TOOK 2 YEARS OF BOB MUELLER
TO FIND OUT THE WHOLE THING WAS
GROUNDLESS.
JIM COMEY BECAUSE HE DID NOT
LIKE DONALD TRUMP, BROKE ALL OF
THE RULES.
IT'S NOT JUST LIKE SPEEDING.
THESE ARE THE BASIC RULES THAT
GOVERN THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
WHAT DID WE GET IN EXCHANGE?
2 YEARS OF WASTED TIME AND
EFFORT AND THE COST OF THE
MUELLER REPORT TO OUR SYSTEM.
IT'S BEEN A DISASTER FOR THE
COUNTRY.
>> Laura: JOHN, THE HOST OF
"HARD BALL," CHRIS MATTHEWS.
>> THEY LEAKED STUFF TO
CHURCHILL ABOUT THE MILITARY
BUILD-UP OF THE GERMANS.
SOMETIMES THERE IS A JUSTIFIABLE
CAUSE.
>> Laura: CHURCHILL AND HITLER.
>> I CAN'T EVEN TELL WHAT HE IS
TALKING ABOUT.
THE REAL PROBLEM IS JIM COMEY
AND NOT DONALD TRUMP.
THIS IG-REPORT IS A DAMNING
INDICTMENT OF SOMEONE WHO WAS AN
FBI DIRECTOR AND CREATED MANY
ABUSES THAT HOOVER DID AGAINST
MARTIN LUTHER KING.
SPREADING INFORMATION TO DAMAGE
AND HARM PEOPLE WHEN HE WAS NOT
GOING TO PROSECUTE HIM.
THIS IS A GUY WHO SHOULD NEVER
HAD BEEN -- I HAVE TO SAY AFTER
READING THE IG-REPORT.
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS